and then the second half is how you
manage the sales team so you can get
wicked consistent sales on a monthly
[Music]
basis
all right who's pumped about sales
sort of pumped about okay so quick
question so i can cater this to you guys
um as i try and tell my team sometimes
i'm going to talk fast you can just
listen fast
so um who here has one person or less
that would mean if you are selling um
doing the majority of the sales in your
company can get
hand raised okay so like half okay
that's perfect and the other half of you
have a sales team multiple two or more
right okay so the name of my
lovely talk um is going to be the closer
framework all right
and so what i'm going to do is break
this
up into two halves the first half is how
you actually manage the conversation
that should say work
you get the idea close the framework and
then the second half is how you manage
the sales team so you can get wicked
consistent sales on a monthly basis
um so first things first who here has
ever struggled with
inconsistent lead quality inconsistent
cac right you're like
i thought i was at a thousand and now
i'm at three thousand my leads are [ __ ]
actually my leads are amazing
uh my sales team is under work now
they're overworked they said there's too
many there's too few they're not being
efficient at setters anyone dealt with
any of that stuff
okay cool so um i've run a lot of sales
teams uh b2b we did outsource sales
company we would fly two gyms
actually sell for them so we'd fill them
up in 30 days with us actually flying
people out and selling
so we've done a lot of sales and this is
the simplest framework that you can use
um and so this is the first of the five
c's so i try to use markets as 5c so
when you go home
you've got 10 c's okay so um the first
one it governs the conversation so
that's kind of for everyone who was
raised there's kind of more of you over
here we're raising your hands about i've
got one person or it's me
this is the governing framework for how
you make the conversation see
is you clarify
why the person is there all right now
when you use this
framework everything that's in your
framework has to be a question only do
not put paragraphs do not put statements
because they will start reading them
they can't think that way only put
questions because they can pause they
can ask another question
they can pause they can ask another
question and they need no intelligence
to do that
which means it's scalable okay so when
you're asking so
all of these buckets are the buckets
under which you want to create the
framework that you're making your sale
so it's like what made you get on the
call what's your goal why is that
important to you what would it look like
12 months from now if this
ideal outcome were to be achieved right
those are the clarification questions
next you label them with a problem
so what i'm hearing is you've done x y
and z
and the missing link has been x whatever
is that right
yes got it i now have a problem you now
have cancer i can cure it
all right next is oh we're going to
overview the pain okay
so i'm assuming not the first person
you've come to to try and solve this
problem so what have you done in the
past
all right i've done x y and z why did
that not work for you obviously it
didn't work because they're on the phone
with you all right so you always have
that advantage because they're on the
phone with you right now
so you're overviewing past pain we call
the pain cycle
you do that until they have nothing left
and you're like awesome and then you
recap the pain
then s you sell the vacation
this is the only thing that your sales
people
have to actually know there's gonna be
three stories that you're gonna tell
them they're gonna be illustrative of
the thing that you were helping them
solve
so an example would be fitness tuition
fitness nutrition and accountability if
i was trying to sell weight loss
right you're usually missing one or two
or all three of these things that's why
you weren't successful right
you couldn't consistently work out you
couldn't consistently eat the right way
or
no one was there to hold you accountable
does that make sense yes
if you're selling leads it would be like
you need your leads to be exclusive you
need them to be timely
you need them to be geographic whatever
like you're going to find three things
and you have to give a short
30 second snippet of why that's
important right if i was trying to
illustrate accountability i'd be like
hey
did your parents ever tell you to brush
your teeth when you grow up you probably
hated it you're like no i don't want to
and they kept doing it over time and
i'll bet you brush your teeth now right
you need someone to hold you accountable
so you create the habit does it make
sense
30 second story they understand it
that's how you sell a vacation
all right e explain away their concerns
away concerns blah blah blah you get the
point all right
that's where you're doing all of your
obstacle overcomes all right crazy
people buy without obstacles normal
people have concerns
you need to overcome them these have to
be drilled all right they have to be
drilled
so that means that you have flash cards
like i need to think about it i have to
talk to my husband
i have to check with my partner i have
to so there's only three by the way if
you don't know what they are
it's price it's stall it's decision
maker all right
so all you have to do is understand what
each of those three are if it's price
it's a description
discrepancy in value they don't
understand the value if it's
decision maker what you have to do is
rely on past agreements that are implied
that that person has already
communicated to the partner
so your partner knows that you're
struggling with these things already
right they know that you're looking for
a solution right
so why do you think they'd be opposed
with you solving the problem that you
already know you have that they don't
agree with
right overcoming okay those have to be
drilled
next one um is uh so we decision maker
we did price
and stall right all you're doing is
teaching someone to make a decision
because people don't like making them
because they fear making mistake
right perfect halfway through okay
so what you're going to do is walk them
through decision making process so how
do we make decisions
either do you do you like me yes or no
do you like the product
yes or no do you think that we'll be
able to help you achieve this outcome
yes or no do you have access to this
amount of money in your bank account or
know someone who does
yes or no yes what card you want to use
right overcome you make them confront
the decision all right
what's your main concern then they tell
you the main concern you overcome
close all right last one is reinforce
the decision
and i like doing this and we included it
after time
is that people back out right so how can
we slam
slam it on them how can we get them
super pumped so immediately afterwards
that's the 30 second video from the
founder being like hey just saw you sign
up for our software
super excited to have you by name
personalized head written card
t-shirt any of those things reinforce
the decision make their feet nice and
hot
make sense that's the closer framework
every single one of these buckets has to
be
questions that are simple for them to
ask
all right so when you're organizing your
script this is the conversation we're
going through does that make sense to
everybody
okay that is the first of the five c's
don't worry the other ones are fast
and it's about how you manage your sales
team okay
don't worry i'll be fast so that's
closer
the next one is don't worry i'm rocking
we're good
okay the next one i should know these
that's okay okay call recordings
and then i'm gonna i'm just gonna write
these down real quick for you so you can
write them down
comms cut
competition okay
so marcos is much smarter than me i
think he's like
the really classy classy person um this
is like from the streets closing 4 000
people
one-on-one sales like weight loss
susie's riding with you know her kids
trying to write permanent marker on the
wall and i'm trying to close her credit
card all right
so close your sequence is how you manage
the framework call recordings if you're
not recording every single [ __ ] call
that your your people are on one you're
not compliant
two you should do it because then they
become more accountable to following the
script
all right you also overview those the
tool that you need to use is gong if you
if you guys sell it via zoom it's the
[ __ ] best it's all i can say use gong
it's amazing all right
comms you need to talk to your team on a
regular basis all right the cadence
there
is daily huddles weekly
101s and when you do the
and then obviously monthly but the um
the daily
huddles are quick all you do is you
share testimonials so they remember why
they're selling
so they get beat up every single day
with knows they need to remember why
they're still doing it
all right from the 101s that you're
doing when you're meeting with them
you're going to record you're going to
have them tag you in three calls their
best call their worst call on their
average call
when you go over in the 101s you're
going to ask them
to show you where they clarified the
problem
where they outlined the paint and then
where they asked for the sale
and where they overcame objections if
they never clarify the pain
and never ask for the sale you don't
make money so that way they always know
that on every [ __ ] call
you always ask for the sale you can
never make a sale if you never ask for
it all right
that's what you from the communication
cadence cut you got to cut the bottom
all right it's the number one thing that
will drive sales teams is by cutting the
bottom 10 percent you do it on a regular
basis
it has to be on a regular basis all
right even if the team is going okay
when you cut the bottom you'll see a 30
jump in productivity
every time so if you can have a
persistent 30 jump why would you not do
that
does that make sense okay competition
last point i'm good i got a minute 20.
okay so competition sales people are
competitive you have to have a
leaderboard that is
published that they can see every single
day that they get notified when every
other guy is making a sale
if it's super high volume it could be
end of day but when they you've got a
bell if you're in person if you're not
in person you have a thread that should
be all the sales guys digging they can
literally send an image or a gif of a
bell
so it's like ring the bell right so that
they know and it says volume they can
see it there's activity there's action
right it's all of momentum
so leaderboard that has to be checked
every day
has to be updated regularly like that
has to be on point
and then competitions we found that six
weeks works best
um in terms of sending them on like
closers go to vegas
or go to the bahamas or whatever it is
and so we put them in three men teams
and that tends to work really well
because they they share best practices
they continue to work with each other
they root for each other so it's not a
cutthroat
um it's just always having top dog um
and
in terms of how much to spend on that uh
25
of one month check is usually the amount
per person
that a prize like that would be right so
if you guys make 70 you might spend 1500
bucks
to send per guy for like a three day or
like a two day weekend it's not
expensive five grand
but it is worth every dollar so to recap
if you want really really consistent
sales
use the closer framework everything has
to be questions do not have statements
have 30-second stories
record your calls make sure you're
sticking to the comp cadence cut the
bottom percentage
and keep it competitive so they stay in
it thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you